hey guys it's Justine I'm very excited
because today you may recognize this
this is the original iPhone the first
generation this is the 8 gigabyte model
I did an unboxing of this fairly
recently and it was sealed unopened I
got it from eBay a lot of you were
speculating on the price but I'll just
leave that up to your imagination
whatever it was that I paid for it was
100% worth it this zone specifically has
a lot of sentimental value because this
phone represents a time in my life where
I basically was trying to figure out
what I was going to do with the rest of
my life at least in the near term future
now going on 11 years of making YouTube
videos 12 actually I just recently had
my 12 year youtube anniversary that's
crazy but a long story short a lot of
things happened because of this phone
this phone inspired me so much to keep
creating content and it's also because
of this phone a video I created that I'm
sure many of you have seen and if you
haven't seen it it's okay it was the
iPhone bill at video I've talked about
it before but this was one of those
videos where people actually saw it and
not just saw it in my immediate fan base
or my friends and family it was
something that was all around the world
and for me being made fun of for making
videos on the internet which is totally
fine because clearly there was something
to all of those making weird videos on
the internet but it gave me this
realization that what I was doing was
actually something and it was important
and it was the future so I kept doing it
and Here I am many many years later so
all in all the reason that you're here
is because you want to see this phone I
just so happened to be going to the
Apple store to get my iPhone 10 fixes
having a bunch of camera issues so they
replaced the camera and while I was
there I just just like hey so I've got
this original iPhone I was making like a
quick little Instagram video thinking
that it wasn't actually going to work
okay we are on a mission and that
mission is to get this iPhone to work no
problem
but my hopes are very high now here I'm
telling you the story of what exactly
happened at the Apple store to get this
phone to work so what was happening is
iTunes wasn't recognizing this phone so
what my friend did at the Apple store
thank you to go to your the absolute
best while my phone was getting fixed
she's like this is easy well we all we
got to do is force it into recovery mode
download whatever the last version of
iOS that this would support oh you sweet
the status bar what's gonna happen video
and vertical Oh No
[Music]
let's see if I recognized a second
I'm freaking out you guys don't
understand oh my goodness look at this
homescreen man
I'm trying really hard not to cry
[Music]
okay I'm having a moment my first
picture
[Music]
go to time
Wow look at this
this is something really did not think
was gonna happen today
and here it is it's officially set up
I'm so excited state to your honor
because we're gonna make some really fun
videos with this so the version of iOS
that just ended up installing was
version 3.1 3 I was really hoping to get
the first 1.0 version of iOS but
honestly just being able to get this
thing to work is super exciting it's
also kind of interesting because I'm not
able to really log in to any of my email
accounts because I use 2-step
authentication so every time that I
enter my password it says it's the wrong
password I'm like no the password is
right but it doesn't actually know how
to authenticate but when you sign in now
it'll open up a browser it'll say enter
your password and then it'll say that
two-step authentication and then you
enter the phone number but didn't quite
work so well on here also what's
interesting is let's see if we can surf
to a website say hello to the future oh
my goodness it's so slow it could be my
Wi-Fi or it could be this phone come on
let's go you can do it there's at the
end of the page that's definitely not
the end of the beige giant step for
iPhone that's quite the scroll you guys
recall you couldn't even copy and paste
in the first version of iOS but here's
the notepad listen to that you actually
can select all copy and paste there also
pose in an app store so downloading apps
was not a thing like that was just not
something that happened whatever came
pre-installed it was what you had
I remember the workaround was people who
are creating html5 apps so essentially
you would go to a website and then that
would kind of be your app so one of the
things that I did try in the Apple Store
is I've wanted to watch a YouTube video
I was like let's watch a YouTube video
on the first iPhone in the Apple Store
the second that I got this thing
activated spoiler alert it didn't work
oh my gosh YouTube isn't available so
it's not gonna work I'm so this is what
the YouTube app looked like it came
pre-installed on everything but that's
what happened this is the first picture
that is on my iPhone it's probably one
of the worst pictures of effort but I
think it really does encompass a lot of
my feelings I was quite surprised
especially because I had zero
expectations and I didn't think that
this was gonna work here's the second
photo that I took just a picture of the
Apple Store so here are the pictures in
high resolution surprisingly the photo
quality is actually not that bad I mean
it's not that great I was also thinking
why wouldn't it be cool to do a video
test but there was no video on the first
iPhone I think there were some sort of
apps if I do remember correctly that it
sort of captured video it was basically
just kind of taking a screen recording
of your camera screen correct me if I'm
wrong but I vaguely remember that so
here's the App Store I haven't tried to
load this yet so let's see what happens
doesn't look like it's loading oh it
loaded go I'm not gonna but he's an AR
app on air see if there's something that
I can download let me see if I can
download the Starbucks app no how will I
get my coffee so it's crazy is it I
can't really do much on here because
there isn't any actual service so the 2g
network is not supported any longer on
AT&T so I really can only do things on
Wi-Fi and since there's no iMessage I
can't actually send any messages at all
you could only send text messages
through a carrier I can't make a phone
call there's no Wi-Fi calling nope call
failed see here's the messages I can't
do anything okay let's go through the
apps here's the calendar i j HQ it's
just not focused I'm very upset of a
thought let's go into photos let's see
what the photo op looks like I now have
three photos me super excited Apple
Store me filming this video so here's
what the share function looks like you
can email the photo assigned a contact
you use as wallpaper so we did YouTube
already obviously no
happened let's try stocks hmm
looking mediocre maps it's kind of crazy
because Google Maps came pre-installed
on here so let's zoom in see where we
can go Arkansas
hello anybody from Arkansas shout out
whether voice memos let's try this out
hello hi play next we have notes just
type some nonsense clock no calculator
oh riveting looks the same actually
here's our settings Apple Store
what's this oh so I wonder if I could
sign in it's not gonna make a difference
because I can't do anything
iTunes let's take a look at this oh no I
quit Mary's all the App Store so let's
take a look what the contacts looks like
at how many contacts though who male I
tried to set up mail but it wouldn't let
me
Safari you saw what that looked like an
iPod I don't have any music so sad this
is also another crazy thing I find it
very strange I know when people say
things like all the universe the
universe it works in mysterious ways I
say it because it really really does I
was in San Francisco and I went to MoMA
and they had this display where it was
made in California so obviously they had
a whole display of Apple products of
course I went in I was making some
videos and taking pictures you guys may
have seen my Instagram story if not I
will add a highlights you guys can check
it out this was one of those moments
which happens all too often it makes you
think how did I happen to be at this
moment at this time for this specific
thing to happen
I was making an Instagram video of these
three sketches and I was like this is
awesome these sketches are sketching out
what a mouse will be and how it will
work so it basically was the prequel to
the mouse that we know today these
illustrations were done in 1983 and it
just so happened that the guy who
who did those illustrations also just
happened to stop by to see the display
and I didn't believe him at first what
are the odds of this and then I'm just
like freaking out because I don't think
he had any idea of what a huge Abba fan
I was so he's like no I really did do
this and his friend that was with him
said yeah he did this he told me some
really cool stories about creating those
sketches and stuff like that but it was
definitely an extremely memorable moment
I just wanted to leave you guys with a
little bit of that video because it was
a really special moment for me mostly
just because of how the universe works
how random occurrences like that
happened and it really is crazy that you
never know who you're gonna use I don't
even know how to explain this but this
is just one of the crazy things that
happens in life so I'm just sitting here
looking at these incredible sketches
here admiring one of these prototypes of
the Apple Mouse and of course one of my
most favorite computers ever and the guy
who did these sketches just walks out of
your birth what went was this 1983 so
1983 so a year before I was bull so I
mean well how does it feel to be here
and just kind of seen your sketches oh
well that's a fair thing to ask I mean
it's sort of like old friends and the
thing is none of you will ever be this
old
you kind of go first thing is have I
done anything of consequence since that
means in sketching when you're not happy
with your sketch you're really happy
with the fact and honored that they've
been displayed and you're wondering what
should I do next
I mean this is incredible though really
and this is so awesome and I just can't
believe it I'm kind of in shock I didn't
even believe him he had to get his
driver's license out and put it don't
show them don't show that no and put it
next to his name right here so that I
would believe it and I did and this is
so cool well thank you so much for
sharing your story with me this is so
cool anything else you want to share
about this just thank you Justine for
passing it along beautifully okay well
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and I appreciate
you guys who may have been here all this
time who may be new it's really cool
just to sort of see the evolution of
Technology I've been able to document so
much of it over the course of my
lifetime and it's amazing just to be
able to still do this and share it with
you guys I'll have some more fun videos
coming up soon so you guys aren't
already subscribed please do so cuz I
just found an old laptop from 2007 this
was the computer that I started my
youtube career on so I look forward to
showing you guys that because wow I
turned that on and I'm like I need to do
a reaction video to some of the things
that I felt crazy oh I'm so excited
again thank you I'll see you later
subscribe hit the bell like this video
or don't do whatever you want to do I'm
out I got to go edit this now because
I'm so excited
[Music]